les vaches mangent du foin depuis des
milliers d'années
ça ça ne change pas mais le climat lui
change et dans ces nouvelles conditions
le foin a de plus en plus de difficultés
à pousser des chercheurs tentent de
trouver de nouveaux forages mieux
adaptée à la chaleur sans trop modifier
le menu millénaire des vaches
au québec il était 2018 a été très chaud
un temps exceptionnel de canicules et de
sécheresses des records de températures
ont été battus 1 était catastrophe pour
la récolte de foin la nourriture
principale des bovins d'après les
projections climatiques
il s'agit de l'été typique que le québec
vivra en 2050
le chercheur d'agriculture et
agroalimentaire canada gilles bélanger a
consacré sa carrière à l'étude des
plantes fourragères qui composent le
foin il est conscient que ces
bouleversements climatiques vont mettre
à mal la production de la nourriture des
vaches pour ce que changements
climatiques sont déjà présents et ça va
continuer donc la question clé je pense
c'est l'adaptation
on a la chance dans le domaine agricole
d'avoir une adaptation qui peut être
progressive et ça va être le cas en
production fourragère on commence alors
un petit pull et d'adaptation le fouet
c'est un mélange de légumineuses et de
graminées
jusqu'à maintenant la combinaison
gagnante sous notre climat a été la
luzerne accompagné de l'afld les hausses
des prix la luzerne une légumineuse
n'est pas menacé par la hausse des
températures bien au contraire ce plus
sur l'atmosphère les légumineuses ont
bénéficié d' avantages de ce co2 pour
leur croissance que les graines les
légumineuses ont un look plus
compétitive par rapport au grain
par contre la compagne de la luzerne la
graminée phléole des prix sera mise à
l'épreuve
alem de températion que maxime frêche on
bosse 20 degrés celsius donc sous les
conditions actuelles espèces qui
performe toujours assez biais un mélange
avec la luzerne entre aude non plus
penser que ces conditions plus chaudes
et plus sèche qu'il faudra les remplacer
avec une hogra me livre à jal
pour trouver la meilleure plante de
remplacement son équipe a étudié
plusieurs graminées sur trois sites de
culture au québec dont celui de saint
augustin de desmaures
après avoir illuminé les moins
performantes
il est resté la fétuque élevée lafitte
sookie des prêts et le brome des prix
parmi ces trois années sans doute que la
fétuque élevée c'est peut-être le plus
de potentiel pour remplacer la fiole du
tri les graminées sont des plantes
vivaces qui reviennent chaque printemps
au moins cinq ans de suite
la fidh ce qu'elles veulent une feuille
qui a land ou relativement luisante et
leurs sons garde le champ suivant on
peut voir un peu ce pub rien donc on la
reconnaît assez facilement avec sont pas
des feuilles assez à s'ériger des à
s'épouiller dessus en espèces du sud une
espèce qui est plus adapté aux
conditions du sud la france ceux des
états unis
les chercheurs ont réussi à percer un de
ses secrets grâce à ses tubes enfoncé
dans le sol
le système racinaire de la fille de ce
qu'elle veut lui permet d'extraire l'eau
du sol jusqu'à 100 cm comparativement à
70 cm pour la fléau le député
les plantes fourragères pérennes qui
composent le foin sont coupés 2 ou 3 x
lite et or en 2040
on prévoit une coupe supplémentaire pour
toutes les régions du québec par rapport
à la fdt les halls des prix la fétuque
élevée présente un net avantage
elle revient en force après chaque flash
elle est très bon reggae très rapide un
très bonne croissance à l'automne car
étant en mesure de tirer profit de ces
conditions plus chaudes et plus sèche
tout en permettant aussi tirer profit de
cette croissance qui va être plus longue
au centre du québec à saint valère
producteurs laitiers de sixième
génération
les thibault père et fils commence la
première récolte de fois ils ont 52
hectares en production de plantes
fourragères qui servent à nourrir leurs
vaches l'opération est réglé au quart de
tour
coupe misant des récoltes aussi lâche
pas deux minutes gaspiller quand le
temps est incertain
ça fait maintenant cinq ans qu'il
récolte la fille de ce qu'il veut ce
champ a été ensemencé l'automne passé en
luzerne est en fait ce qu'il veut ou
ferrer qu'il faudrait à la jambe et
s'est bien développé puis l'a fait
chuter ben dispersé bush il mais ce nom
n'est ce soit dans l'entreprise
eric est le responsable des cultures il
a remarqué que la nouvelle graminées a
augmenté ses rendements points par
rapport à ce que lui donnait la fpt
l'école des prés le mythe comme on
l'appelle souvent le mais quand on
utilisa avait en lava premier cops et on
avait un bon volume pif à 2.6 a su
premier puis quand on sait qu'en art la
deuxième coupe une nouvelle tâche de
l'avion eric thibout est impressionné
par la vitalité de la fille de ce qu'il
vit coupé 4 5
on peut on peut dire qu'il ya également
un premier feuilles le reggae ou était
très bien qu'on allait la reprends ici
bien refait son ce sont le début des
pillages
la fétuque élevée avec ses feuilles
ériger des pointus n'est pas parfaite
brutt et fraîche pas de sou rage et les
moins douce au palais que l'afld les
halls des prêts mais servis en ensilage
demi secs ou pré fans et la fille de ce
qu'elle veut et ne rebute pas les
ruminants d'ailleurs à la lumière de
l'étude menée avec l'université laval le
remplacement de la flotte des prêts dans
les ensilages par cette nouvelle
graminées n'entraîne aucun effet négatif
sur la production laitière
c'est ce que patrick thibault constate
tous les jours avec les fourrages de
services sous forme d'ensilage les
vaches s'alimente bien sûr tout
le but qu'ils assurent
l'autre aspect comme trouve aussi la
fermentation dénonce le même
qui fait possible
ce baptême de l'image
les prévisions climatiques font
réfléchir les producteurs de lait car le
fouet c'est moins simple que ça en a
l'air
on a sombré des sécheresses ou des coûts
des températures plus froides ou tel à
chaleur sur une lente décelable la fête
se sont planqués stable là dessus
les pays de l'europe du nord qui récolte
comme nous l'a phléole des prêts se
posent les mêmes questions
ils cherchent la bonne combinaison
d'espèces de plantes fourragères pour
faire face au changement de climat
c'est les thibault semble avoir trouvé
la bonne recette gilles bélanger
rappelle que la formule n'est pas
universelle la réalité géographique de
chaque ferme est différente
il faut toujours prendre en contre nos
conditions de sol les zones climatiques
dans laquelle on est et les besoins
qu'ont en termes d'alimentation animale
donc il faut prendre l'ensemble des
espèces qui sont disponibles de
plusieurs petits bouts au québec la
partir de s'en faire un choix éclairé
sur ce qui le meilleur mélange d'espèces
pour notre ferme à nous la ferme
thibault a réussi à maintenir une bonne
production de ces espèces fourragères
ces médaillés du mérite agricole ont
compris qu'il devait s'adapter pour ne
pas subir les contrecoups des
changements climatiques
il est vache semble très bien vivre
cette transition
[Musique]